lebron james gets on the back side of
the zone
this is a horse shot rondo gets into the
seam uses the left hand
look how high that goes off i'm not even
going he starts him up
jay crowder with poor body position he
spins out
no ball pressure on rondo kyle kuzma has
come on as is rajon rondo
well this is when james takes his normal
rest
down 13 frank vogel stays with his
normal rotation
espn probability now is 99.8
james goes inside and throws it down
limited defensively limited on the
backboard
but can function offensively rondo nice
feet inside
and the finish for anthony davis who's
now in double figures
tremendous feed oh i mean this just
i mean he's a better competitor than
that and banks it in
and coach one of the adjustments we see
the heat made
from game two that basket went in by
rondo
rondo calling for davis
[Applause]
nice feet inside good patience from
rajon rondo in the setup for anthony
davis james making plays all of a sudden
the next time down the floor he says
help me
rondo help help me rondo and he does the
job
this time little pick-and-roll action
forces the help and then
finds anthony davis diving rondo
excuse me playoff rondo that is about to
be
championship rondo right to left spin as
the shot clock
winds down over the very
rondo drives gets inside back out
caldwell pope for three
puts it in 61-30
with a minute to play here in the second